bienvenidos al programa especial de fin
de año del Salvador es2021 fue marcado
por la decisión del Congreso de mayoría
oficialista de destituir y reemplazar a
los magistrados constitucionales de la
Corte Suprema de Justicia y al Fiscal
General acción que provocó una condena
internacional y de sectores de la
oposición que denunciaron un atropello a
la separación de poderes lo anterior
Washington incluido en una lista de
actores corruptos o antidemocráticos a
personajes cercanos al presidente Nayib
Bukele dando inicio a las tensas
relaciones que El Salvador y Estados
Unidos sostienen hoy en día por otro
lado el mandatario salvadoreño convirtió
a El Salvador en el primer país en
adoptar el bitcoin como divisa de curso
legal la medida ha sido rechazada por
buena parte de la población Bukele
también cerró la puerta a la
legalización del aborto al extruir ese
punto de su propuesta de reforma
constitucional dando un duro golpe a
esta lucha impulsada por el movimiento
feminista
este reportaje analizaremos algunos
temas de la polémica gestión del
gobierno salvadoreño
como todas las semanas Sara García se
alista para salir al aire
un podcast para visibilizar las luchas
feministas de toda la región
estos retrocesos democráticos que se
encargan en los cuerpos de las mujeres y
que en temas como la penalización soluta
del aborto la criminalización de mujeres
se agrava el mural de pañuelos verdes
como el presidente moderno y hasta sin
embargo
pero la posición de Bukele frente al
aborto no es la única decisión contraria
a los deseos de la población
convertir el bitcoin como moneda de
curso legal es una iniciativa que el
presidente Millennial impuso y que aún
no logra ganar el entusiasmo en la
población
para un país en El Salvador en el cual
la mitad de la población se encuentra en
situación de pobreza en esa alta
volatilidad muchas veces la diferencia
entre que puedan comprar un plato de
comida en imponer por voluntad a juicio
del politólogo Álvaro Artiga estos
rasgos del gobierno expresan una deriva
autoritaria
diría que no podemos decir en este
momento que ya esto es una dictadura
como tal
Ana lo que tenemos para mí es un
gobierno autoritario que se expresa en
todos esos comportamientos verdad en
donde él es el que dicta hágase
buque le llega la mitad de su periodo
según diferentes encuestas con elevados
índices de popularidad pero ciertas
decisiones como la adopción del bitcoin
y su intolerancia todo tipo de crítica o
cuestionamiento han exacerbado algunas
manifestaciones de rechazo dentro del
país que aunque pequeñas pueden
significar una disminución del optimismo
de la ciudadanía frente al desempeño
gubernamental uno de los puntos críticos
para el próximo año como advierten
algunos economistas será si se concreta
o no un acuerdo con el Fondo Monetario
Internacional en caso que si significará
un ajuste al cinturón de la economía
salvadoreña de un 4% del PIB un apretón
que podría resultar impopular de lo
contrario el país se quedaría en un
préstamo de 1300 millones de dólares
necesarios para dar un respiro a las
maltrechas finanzas públicas un aspecto
importante a favor de bucle y de qué
depende en gran parte la valoración
positiva de su gestión es el control de
la delincuencia y la inseguridad ese
caudal de simpatía que lo mantendrá si
al menos sostiene la tendencia en la
reducción de homicidios que este año
tuvo un promedio de 3 asesinatos diarios
cuando años atrás fue considerado uno de
los países más violentos del mundo